let me welcome you all to the third of
the third session of the ehsan yarshater
lectures the past two days we've heard
from Professor Sanjay Subramanyam on two
complementary aspects of what we may
call indoor Persian and indo-europeans
aspects of the passionate world and the
personal texts actually as the second
lecture very clearly showed us of today
the purpose of this session we thought
would be to try to broaden a little bit
the the discussion the conversation not
only among the panelists here but to our
audience as well to try to as the topic
has been advertised in the indy and the
poster about conceptualizing a
passionate achievement our borrowing
that from Marshall Hudson's seminal work
venture of Islam in the early modern
period although we may actually extend
this a little bit too early modern and
modern or if for some of us who would
like to actually venture and go back to
the pre-modern period and I in a moment
would try in the few minutes that I have
to open the discussion to try to raise
some issues with reference to the
meaning and the significance of the idea
of the person eighth or the passionate
zone or passionate domain
before that I would like to thank our
panelists I would like to thank
professor brahmanyam my colleagues
in the history department and their
other departments starting from here
with process stiff fingers the
specialist of early modern European and
American history with a special
reference to the transatlantic networks
both in terms of trade and cultural and
commercial connections between the
between Europe and the new world in the
early modern times his book in 1688
particularly among many others of his
contributions addresses the question of
the significance of the development of
the trade in the transatlantic and its
significance in the way that the whole a
European economy and the European
society has been affected by that and of
course with interest in other areas
including the Indian Ocean a Sanjay
Subramanya of whom I have introduced in
the first session and he was very
introduced in the second is a
distinguished professor at UCLA in early
modern history with a special interest
in South Asia but with the broader
interest not only in the Indian Ocean
but in the neighboring lands as well as
in contact with Europe as he puts it the
connected histories in terms of how a
South Asia in the early modern times
developed a range of contacts with the
outside world we had some of this
yesterday in this lecture we have dr.
Supriya Gandhi who is in the Department
of Religious Studies here with interest
also in religious and particularly Sufi
trends in South Asia or more I would say
the personal world with an interest in
how the development of the Sufi orders
how the ideas related to the Persian at
world acts
spread across the subcontinent
with many interesting synthesis that
comes out of it we have my colleague
also professor Allen Mihai who is a
specialist of early Ottoman history with
much broader range of course
environmental history has produced a
number of works including his study of
the Nile River
more recently study of environmental
history of the Ottoman Empire that just
came out and both of them are works of
great significance as the breakthrough
in the field of Middle Eastern Studies
in the early modern times and the
inspiration for many and finally I have
professor cash Rogers V of the
department of artistry who is a
specialist of Safavid artistry and
architecture art and architecture would
also interest in a broader topic of how
the Safavids world actually interacted
and was in conversation with South Asia
and with Europe so her work includes a
fascinating study of the complex of
shared inaudible II inaudible which is a
remarkable construction of the Elizabeth
II period and more recently a study of
the mosque architecture around the
Islamic world so with this introduction
I would go on and say a few words about
why I rethought that and when I say we
actually was in conversation throughout
this period with dr. Valley jihad who
had a very significant interest in some
aspects of this interaction and I'm sure
we are going to hear from him later
since Marshall Hudson is coining the
term passionate in the 1960s
the significance of Persian culture in
particular Persian language and
literature in the Eastern Islamic world
we have noticed that in the 1960s on
more significantly since 1990s and the
past decade the idea of personate had
found a greater popularity and accept
acceptance within the field of both one
might say cultural literature culture
and history two years ago or three years
ago in 2014 we held a conference here
with the help of ossified chef dr.
adventure on the subject of
conceptualizing the passionate and I
think it was a very successful
conference the Proceedings of it
hopefully is going to appear by the end
of this year we had a number of very
interesting papers about aspects of
passionate and the idea was basically to
try to explore to what extent we can
speak of passionate beyond the field of
language and literature whether indeed
this is a network that has a certain
possibly commercial of possibly modes of
political culture that it's shared in
this whole region is it something
perhaps a trade of networks of Sufism
this is all a can be a can be included
into the concept of a passionate and
today my hope is that perhaps the panel
would like to see that in the age that
we are thinking more in terms of global
history we're thinking more in terms of
connected history we think more in terms
of inter-regional or cross regional
histories whether or for that matter
cultures whether we can speak of a
person a zone that has so far at least
to my readings has somewhat been
overshadowed by the emergence of early
modern or modern domains whether it's
European colonialism since the 19th
century late 18th century whether it is
the emergence in the 20th century the
post-colonial era of the construct that
we know as the Middle East and it's kind
of very dominating in terms of its
coverage within the academia and outside
whether such constructs in a sense
overshadowed the emergence or greater
emphasis on the place of the passionate
or whether indeed the concept of the
passionate why itself would make sense
whether we can think in terms of South
Asia Central Asia the Iranian plateau
the the Caucasus and in Anatolia are
possibly as an area of the personal
geographical domain and why is it that
over the course of the early modern
times and modern times this area
gradually a shrunk in size whether these
are the forces of blind nationalism
whether it's the emergence of the
vernaculars whether all of these factors
played a part in undermining a greater
interest in this or whether it's as a
matter of fact it may color argue that
it doesn't make sense to trade to try to
put too much emphasis on the Persian
eight world if it's only a question of a
shared language the lingua franca of the
region or a movement of the ideas
movements of religious movements
movement of literature and literary
texts that in a sense wrote this area
together yesterday for instance in the
lecture by Professor Subramanya I was
impressed to see that how much
passionate text or passion text in the
subcontinent really is the medium
through which many of the idea
has been transmitted from Europe to
South Asia and vice versa and I would
like to see whether really we can expand
on these themes whether we can as in the
first lecture for Subramanyam pointed
out that how the merchant classes play a
very important part in the growth of the
Indo person connections in the early
modern times whether these can be seen
as some kind of ground upon which would
be able to think in a broader sense of a
network called a personal network and
what's the significance of it
everything's in terms of transatlantic
Mediterranean were a South Asian Indian
Ocean world whether we can think in
terms of the personal zone or a personal
domain I would stop here we would have
about five to ten minutes for this every
offer participants and then we would
open it to a general discussion so cash
where would you like to I feel bad that
my colleagues at the table can't see the
images and I don't know if you could
turn the light down a little bit or is
there going to be a problem would you
like to go around maybe for five minutes
John - musical chairs which kind of
control customs would say alright thing
you have you enjoy better okay so on I
just have a few notes and much of it is
in response to Professor subramanyam's
lectures the last couple of days which
has been so incredibly provocative and
so I'd like to contribute a few thoughts
from my perspective as a historian of
the Safavid period and somebody who
works on art and architecture material
culture and I hope that it'll be
fruitful for - opening up in some ways
the conversations we've had the past two
days already so your professor Emmanuel
with our stories of Iranian merchants as
a bus brought up in Bekaa knee court and
they were of course joined by many other
luminaries right so we had from Sufis to
poets to artists as you see here and up
the summit is one of those storied
artists who moves with Humayun the story
goes along with misha a delhi from the
Safavid court in Tabriz and then called
excuse me has been after that moves to
india and the story goes of how he
becomes indigenized right in a sense
that how the work that had been this
very particular kind of classical
Safavid work comes to india and
something changes about his own hand and
that's something we need to really
problematize a little bit more in terms
of what that really means for foreign
artists to change the way they look and
and what that might say about first of
all agencies and encounters and also
just the breadth of somebody's work now
people like up to summer than others
forward Sufis and so on came with dreams
of wealth and prestige of course and we
have to be reminded that India this time
was the wealthiest nation Empire
anywhere right so when they are all
coming and we are talking about the sort
of unilateral movement migrations into
the subcontinent it's for a very mundane
reason on the one hand on the other hand
especially in the case of Iran they're
coming because of religious persecution
and so there are two very important
motivations for that migration one is
monetary and one is ideological and
those things are happening
címon simultaneously now I think it's
interesting to think about this
so-called uneven migration and what I
would like to suggest is that it really
wasn't that an event even and to think
about what India was sending west and in
particular in the case of sack of the
Divine what while maybe Indian subjects
themselves were not moving west to Iran
in particular at least not in large
numbers that we can tabulate very easily
of course merchants were as you
mentioned you know we had a very large
Bunya communities for example in Isfahan
but the ideals of kingship and authority
were emanating from India West and I
think that something really important to
think about and especially serve to take
for example this story of Akbar and
Charles never wrote about this his his
movement his barefoot to Thermage to
fatehpur sikri to secret and the story
goes of course of Akbar and you see him
he is the figure here in a simple JAMA
with no shoes on it was a barefoot
pilgrimage that he took because he was
childless and he wanted to go and have
he prayed to the Sufi chef to grind him
a son and an heir and this is of course
an important trope in the story of piety
and the locals really performed this
piety very publicly now it's no surprise
that a few years later Shah Abbas is
going to do exactly the same thing right
then again that he is going to have
barefoot pilgrimages to Agra be barefoot
those images to measure to the shrine of
imam reza and he's going to couches also
and this image of piety and that becomes
an idea and an idea that is coming
really from an awareness of of the
environment and of course it's also they
ironic because at the same time Shabbos
is the one who's really suppressed
suppressing much of this idea of a Sufi
influence that occurs very much playing
into another example I mean I think that
is that of capitals right so we know
that the Mughals were very well known
and in particular Akbar when he sets up
what a [ __ ] Cree and in sort of as a
mark of again respect for setting to see
for the shave Abbas is very aware of
this and so we hear of this move from
cuisine down to Isfahan and we've talked
a lot you know historian pre-marked that
it was a you know strategic move it was
away from the Ottoman borders but this
idea of having a large capital that
really marked who you were is something
that the
learning Iran is learning this not only
from India but also of course from the
Ottomans right so those are the business
movement that is happening of ideas
across the board of this idea of you
know Istanbul is a very important city
we have travelers that are remarking
about these grand cities of these
Cosmopolis and for Iran that's an
important aspect that they are really
becoming very aware of and so when do
you think of this behind and we see it
and we have again people writing about
the Madani Shah being you know 10 times
the size of San Marco there's a
awareness not just about India and Iran
and and Turkey but also of Italy of
other grand cities of the world and the
Society of connected history that my
colleagues have brought about is an
important one to think about but of
course we also know this idea of cities
is something that's discussed by
colleagues of ours such as Salem Carew
who works on the Ottomans
Paul the 10th key works on the Safavids
and some Sharma who works on the Mughals
have written about the shared language
of cities of the sharing gears or the
shiatsu again cities become the slow
side of a particular identities in this
early modern period and it's shared
across the across the board and of
course this idea of romantic encounters
and as we know you know discuss it was a
lot of work done on the spring age of
beloved's the water and ruse and
mathematical Berkeley have written about
and whether what you might think about
it and their relationship again to
connect that moment in time to again to
what's happening in Europe this idea of
courtly cultures and romance and so on
and we certainly see this in Iran too
but these works and I'm doing the
terrible thing that our historians are
not supposed to do which is going
through these images and not really
talking about them so excuse me for my
five minutes so the grand a terrible
thing my students should not do this but
I think with this style of painting for
example has been called a firing he
sighs neither the the European mode and
what does that mean that's something we
need to interrogate more because we can
talk about the sort of person eight
culture and he's all coming to this
realm of Persian language Persian poetry
image-making has its histories and they
very deeply embedded but something
starts to happen at this moment where we
are again becoming aware as our
conversation yesterday was about of a
different kind of an insertion now what
I want to just end with is Europe is the
one thing the outlier here and I'm
trying to figure out exactly how to work
it in and in professor sonsoo / - talked
yesterday me think how it's really
important for us to disentangle first of
all method logically this idea of
Christianity which is this mode of the
Jesuits and others are bringing in and
the European right because Christianity
as you can see from this image of an
Iranian Bishop is something which is
naturalized we have large communities of
Christians in India in Iran as well as
Jews so this idea of recognition you
they recognize each other in this idea
of religious empathy there's something
else happening with the Europeans of
course and that's something I still I'd
like to throw out there and to think a
little bit more about and with that
question you know I mean I think this is
for example this image of a large which
is right here and we have it in by Nike
again this is a shout-out to our home
institution it's fascinating how is this
read how is this understood
right when you're overlaying the image
of how large with that of the
crucifixion of Christ
what are we understanding and what are
we learning and then we do it in a
particular hand with the shading the
modeling of the figure right so there's
something else going on here and I think
we need to look at texts but also the
other kinds of images and material
culture that we have that I think and
like language and like these bureaucrats
and these merchants are intermediaries I
think there's the spaces where this
translation is taking place as well so
that's my intervention then I do bite
you back and we should we leave her
large in the back person two-parter okay
thank you
there you go he can be asked st. of the
academic
perhaps you can have more life now
they're not going to be more images no
like the like so dr. Gandhi okay thank
you very much t-shirt uh actually I I do
have a couple of things that relate to
some of the issues that you brought up
and three main points prompted by
professor super minions lectures the
first point relates to the circulation
of people between different regions of
this version of zone and in this regard
I'd like to highlight a sort of
methodological issue of all constraints
regarding the Persia net textual archive
which informs what the possibilities as
well as the limits of how we might
approach and study the movements of
people or you know separate graphical
studies of certain groups and and this
is because the vast majority of the
archives exists as books or codex's you
either printed Rippa graphed books or
unpublished manuscripts sometimes
published critical editions especially
regarding the south asians repression at
archive so much of this remains
untouched by the digital revolution that
has made for instance made possible made
available vast quantities of Arabic
materials you know so for instance
scholars like John Watson Monique
Bernard others those loads of others
have been able to use these digital
archives to do pose of the graphical
studies again relating to Arabic
materials but with regard to the Persian
materials you know this isn't yet
available so of course the situation
necessitates other reading practices
when it comes to the study of groups and
and individuals at the earth
migrants or travelers you know such as
the the artist whom you talked about the
various travelers who professor
Subramanyam has has written about and I
guess you know one when a special
challenge here is addressing not only
the histories of lead travelers and
migrants of those who might have
produced works of art or poetry but
those who are often unnamed who might
have made these routes of exchange
possible whether these are the couriers
who carried the letters of Metamora
govern to Johnny and Bhavani or the
merchants who might have supplied the
Mughal elites with a favourite melons
from val or other Central Asian great
for pomegranates from yes my second
point relating to Professor Subramanyam
second lecture relates to the
translation or carry on cross of
institutions and practices across
empires this is connected to some of the
points that you brought up which be you
know and so and and sometimes this
exchange of ideas and practices is aided
by the circulation of material objects
checks such as books you know one
example for instance is the model of
sovereignty in the court of Ibrahim Adil
Shah who had this Iranian Court equals a
Hooley you know I think mentioned in one
in one of the talks who produce these
really elaborate prose professes to work
that he either presented to every other
show or works composed you know by the
by the Emperor and you know here he
extolled the wrong way to bring in
others shall reconciles various
realities such as that of corrent Islam
you know you think save a sandalwood of
in the sandal paste of Brahmans to cool
the headache of of Islam you know how
these dualities reconciled in the
Emperor you know this is a model of
sovereignty that of course
resonances with the Mughal emperor Akbar
but then we also see a manuscript of the
huis processes landing up in Sharjah
House Court you know where this also
would have been read and consumed by
Sharjah has son eldest son and heir
Donna sugar who at this point thought of
himself really as an emperor in the
making and sort of modeled his own kind
of royal self-fashioning
in a very similar manner one also sees
these these exchanges of course across
empires as as you mentioned we innovate
sky pass you know there's the example of
translation as an imperial practice as
well another of course mogul
translations are very famous the mobile
translations of Indian Sanskrit material
some of which came up during the talks
such as the affairs of sponsored
transformation of the vison nama the
Mahabharat and several other indict
texts there was a of course Gallo
shoku's translations as well a bit of
the punishes and one also sees you know
to have to enter a lesson exchange and a
similar transition practices and a
taking taking place in various Iranian
courts you know for instance the Bible
translations response sponsored by Shah
Abbas or translations of Jewish and
Christian scriptures later on by Nadia
you know interesting account of which is
recorded by actually a Kashmiri Muslim
associated with her so in apart from
looking at the ideas of circulation and
connect interconnection and I also
wanted up to bring up the perhaps limits
and boundaries within this version its
own the issue of heterogeneity and
difference you know the vendor person
acumen or even within the Indian
subcontinent itself Persian his networks
within the Indian subcontinent
I think in some scholars have argued for
a shared ethic of sociability and
comportment that might have linked the
Iranian travelers with Indian Muslims
you know they are that connected them
you know certainly you know there are
certain texts like Saudis coolest and
that were that was read very widely in
South Asia but there's still a strong
sense of difference you know sometimes
in admission that persists in the
writings of many Iranians who visited or
migrated to India that also needs to be
accounted for and furthermore within the
context of the subcontinent
we have several changes taking place
just in terms of the people
participating in these Persian of
networks so in the 18th century there
there is no fluorescence of Hindus
writing and Persian and with the
expansion of the bureaucracy and the
fact that there were several Hindus who
for generations in aus is not just not
first-generation Persian learn that
learners but here they had carried on a
tradition of Persia Persian learning for
generations so they were I mean reading
publics that are created you know we
might see new kinds of circulation of
texts so always a tricky issue in South
Asia because we don't really know
whether much about manuscripts
calculation earlier with certainty is it
serendipity or is it just that they were
you know certain takes that have
survived or not it's hard it's hard to
tell whether they exchange manuscript
archive actually reflects what
circulated but there really but there
does seem to be enough lawrence of
hindus the writing in persian writing
themselves into histories of operation
literature and then you this also brings
up the issue of you know whether they
were multiple different leading publics
you know whether
within the dispersion and so on whether
people necessarily read the same kind of
thing for instance there was a small
group of mainly Hindus who adopted Sufi
rhetoric translated in thick text often
from a vernacular interpret into Persian
and use the same kinds of pleasure in
mystical poetry that was circulated
amongst them seeing some sort of tell
who is reading whole similar kinds of
poems are circulating amongst them but
you know but does this necessarily
remover across a larger group the author
of with died chronically of there are
changes again with the shift to print
Persian very much persisted even through
the 19th century in many ways there was
a lot of print production in in Persian
as well different of course kinds of
texts that were being produced with
publisher like when she never cash or
the vast range of texts in whether we
had translations of reminds perhaps you
know for Hindus who were accustomed to
reading the sacred texts and Persian you
know all the others were Persian classic
syndication poets as well and then you
know there were other publishers like
the museum ahamed Shirazi malik al kitab
out of bombay who might have in his own
publications you know at a different
kind of audience you know that's
overlapped more with with iran is what
was being read in Iran so I think I'll
pause there with it's just this idea of
heterogeneity and limit we gotta watch i
think after hearing two very sorts will
as you put it interventions with about
South Asia and the Iranian Plateau
laughs I think here I'm hoping from
Allen more about the kind of an ottoman
side and what's happening there in the
emergency system a trainee and world
with ultimately very important article
okay I'll do my best okay so my comments
are are sort of under two headings one
is frontier and the other is ecumene I
wanted to ask professor Subramanyam
about what kind of frontier is the
Deccan frontier exactly a lot of the
literature that developed around
theorizing the frontier as you will know
came from the American West and it's
it's basically a dirty word now there's
also some work about China our colleague
professor Peter Purdue for example has
done good work as you know on that and
those are very specific kinds of
frontiers in which we have large tribal
Confederations and English essays the
American State or the Chinese state
pushed West in both cases in sort of
conquest and expansion it strikes me
that the that the Deccan frontier is
vastly different than that and so I'd
like to hear a bit more about how you
might theorize that frontier versus
other frontiers I mean Richard Eaton has
also used frontier in a South Asian
context and I would be curious to hear
more about that in it so to give the
Ottoman side of things for a second and
the Ottoman Empire we don't have that
kind of frontier the we don't have a
great frontier as we did in the in the
American West or in western China so we
have the relationship between settled
and nomadic communities is a very
generative one in the history of the
Middle East and the Ottoman Empire in
specific but other parts of the Middle
East as well
so we have these communities interact
paying a great deal sometimes they fight
work sometimes the intermarry mostly
they rate and trade and I think this is
also seen for example in the fact that
most of the major cities of the region
that we call the Middle East as a bus
problematized for us quite nicely
most of those cities are not port cities
right Cairo Damascus Tabriz Baghdad Ron
and deadly strikes meal is potentially a
part of that story but I think in in
temperature it's much more complicated
particularly because you do have major
port cities and you have you have a very
different kind of frontier given the
Indian Ocean trade so I just love to
hear more about how you think about the
frontier in the South Asian context the
other major question that I have is
about the idea of the ecumene and
specifically the Persian eight and it
might question sort of echo some of the
things that are possible at the
beginning so I went back to Hoxton a
little bit and it's a very clunky book
reading it in 2017 so he identifies as I
read it for cultural zones the
Mediterranean visit is managed to the
Mediterranean the Nile to the Oxus the
Indian and the Chinese so that's I mean
that's almost a Samuel Huntington so the
Nile to the Oxus is the kind of Islamic
age for him so India is outside of that
so so I thought I want to put that out
there at the beginning um so if you
think the Mediterranean for a second
right broad down is the best model we
have for thinking about the
Mediterranean as a region as we all know
and his analysis about thinking about an
ecumenical want to use that language has
to do with with both an ecological story
of crops and seasonality and thinking
about that relationship of agriculture
and ecology to politics and also his
economics story is very important of
trade
across the Mediterranean so if you think
about the Persian a using using the
model of brought down a little bit it's
not clear to me exactly how that works I
mean the Persian it is not an ecological
zone as far as I understand I mean the
horse trade that you mentioned in the
first lecture is a very interesting way
of thinking about that myth but maybe it
is an ecological zone I mean certainly
in terms of disease pathogens and stuff
an argument can be made for that we
could make an economic argument on the
basis of trade and that seems like a
strong one to make for a kind of Persian
unity of a person a unity sufi networks
of course that that many people have
raised already so I would love to hear
iris I mean that's the point of this
panel right is to help us to think about
what is this acumen exactly so it to be
devil's advocate
it seems to me still that the persian
eight is more a cultural designation
than an economic or a political or a
religious one and I think we should
maybe think about if we are attracted to
Persian it because it's a kind of non
nation state of formation of political
zone and it's also a non it's a non
Islamic 8-1 right it is it is
particularly Persian it of and I think
that's in fact that important and
probably 98 right right and and so that
gets me to also thinking about how we
conceptualize the acumen so again
everything about the Ottoman world the
Safavid world and and the mobile world
particularly in the south of it case we
have a fairly weak state right in the
Ottoman case we have for you know two
hundred fifty years of the empires
history and for all of mobile history we
have minority and Muslims ruling over
the majority non-muslim of population
it's not at all clear that Ottoman
culture means anything on the ground in
various places so acumen to me the
vision I have in my mind is a kind of
blob or a border and you're either in
the ecumene or out of
acumen and that I think stands in some
tension with Professor subramanyam's
work on connected histories
I mean connected strikes me as something
quite different from this I mean might
we think of the ecumene as as something
that involves discrete points and
connections we use the term network a
lot so there are many many people within
the kind of blob of the ecumene don't
actually I think are not captured by the
terminology of personate or Islamic cake
or ottoman for that matter so I would
just I guess love us all to sort of
think about the complexity of this idea
of the ecumene and maybe some of its
problems thank you so much please good
working again interesting questions that
pertain I'm sure there would be a chance
to try to think more and discuss this
two points that you have raised now we
are moving to a European world and try
to see how approach the pinkest is going
to make some connections was connected
histories here for right Syd oh so first
of all I sort of I'm beginning to sort
of relish very much this sort of
position of being the outsider last week
I was the non-american in American
history conference today I'm you know
the non person not not not working on
Islamic eight Empire's an Islamic
civilizations talking here tomorrow and
the non sociologists at a sociology
conference and the most tomorrow morning
and and you know the most biggest
outsider I was this week was where my
elder son got sick and then psych hence
I couldn't go to the Tuesday lecture I
had to play Game of Thrones with with my
sons and that there I was a real
outsider because I've ever seen the game
of Thrones I don't know what the game of
Thrones is but it was a great moment I
think my greatest triumph academic
triumph ever actually won the game after
five hours so uh so I enjoy being an
outsider
and there's certain sort of sense but I
I guess I mean in many ways the kind of
questions that I have and I'll talk a
little bit more specifics have to do
with both historic izing a kyumin's more
generally and I guess I'm going to talk
about the the Atlantic world and its
relationship to to Professor Subaru on
Ian's world in a certain sense but I
also want to sort of think about how
politics might be important in sort of
thinking about the ecumene so let me
just sort of begin with with the story
and and you know kiss fire pointed out
that you know we're we're speaking here
at Yale and like all Yelp if we always
have to start with with Yale so so I
started with as rest' Isles 1766 history
of India which is really a history of
Mughal India now he ever not didn't
actually finish this he just created
notes for this this history of India um
and uh it's so he the it's a very
sympathetic account I think of the
Mughal Empire and he describes a sort of
what sort of successor States as forming
a kind of Federation or Confederation
that could have maintained peace in in
the subcontinent if it wasn't for the
injection of the inevitable nefarious
and evil actor the French that it was
the sort of injection of do play into
into South Asia that sort of eliminated
this possibility of an Islamic
Confederation that would have kept the
peace in South Asia and whatever of
course allowed the British to trade
happily but but that's by part and then
of course but the real the real the real
evil part of the story is that the the
Britain Robert Clive decided decided to
imitate the French model and created
this incredibly nefarious rule in in
Bengal which is the point of writing
this story in 1766 right after the
Assumption
of the Diwani and it should be noted
that this this sort of image of the
centrality I think of Mughal India to
Atlantic conceptions of empires in the
world is something which has been under
underestimated it should be one should
remember that the text which made Thomas
Paine a kind of pop star in North
America was not common sense common
sense as the Commission that he got
having become a pop star and they would
attacked his account of Robert Clive and
the nefarious rule in Bengal which
actually made him an important obtain
important figure which is why Benjamin
Rush commissioned him to write common
sense so the questions that I wanted to
ask is what does Stiles this historical
attempt tell us about the Atlanta the
relationship between the Atlantic and
Persia net worlds and the
conceptualization thereof and then I
want to ask some questions about why why
in 1766 and what that means so let me
start off with the Atlantic world not
part of part of you know stuff I've been
writing you know nothing anybody reads
this is the great thing about being an
outsider nobody ever reads anything you
say but but you know I've been trying to
suggest for a long time that the
Atlantic world despite despite what some
very distinguished scholars that is is
not an enclosed space and it's always
related to outside areas in theory in
the 16th and 17th centuries and in
practice in the 18th centuries
nevertheless I think it's really
important to sort of to sort of see this
in many ways and dialogue with with with
this kind of version of world because
merchants play an incredibly important
role not only as as commercial actors
although I think commercial actors are
very important but also as cultural
carriers of transmit as people who
transmit material objects which have
significance but also a series a series
of ideas so the early settlement in
in British North America and I'll
confine myself so they're always had
some sort of deep relationship to the
world outside - it was always as
conceived of as a route to something
vaguely conceived of as the East
although China played a much larger role
in this imagination in the 16th and 17th
centuries then did then did this kind of
Persian at world so we know that Henry
Henry Henry Hudson Henry Hudson
imagined that he was discovering a
Northwest Passage out to the east and an
Edward Williams as Toronto pointed out
to me yesterday wrote a text in 1650 in
West Virginia was imagined as a southern
route to travel to what he called the
purr of the Persian and Industry empires
by way in the South Seas and this was of
course the same aspiration with those
who founded Georgia in the 1735 that
actually creating Georgia would greet
make it much easier to create a route a
roundabout route a southern route to
South Asia so that that was the sort of
imagination in the 16 16th and 17th
centuries and but in the in the late
17th and 18th centuries there was
massive consumption of goods of material
objects from South Asia from this kind
of Persian at world in North America
Indian silks calicos tea and and it's
important to realize them and this is
just something I sort of and in the
1750s of course British Americans
frequently have themselves portrayed in
the so called Indian style so portraits
which are now and what is that
institution in Cambridge whatever it is
that the art museum up up there what's
it called the volume of video yeah oh no
no no the one in Cambridge oh yeah okay
right Africa how's the fog yeah yeah
that one right there a bunch of
portraits of North Americans in this in
this version in every single port book
in a
important North America record the
importation of goods from from from
South Asia and of course this created a
problem how do you pay for these goods
when when Europeans and North Americans
had nothing that that people in South
Asia wanted of course the key was
American silver but despite the
aspirations of many people in Virginia
no silver mines where ever discovered a
in along the Blue Ridge in fact it's
required trading to Spanish America and
how did they get a get a silver out of
Spanish America well it required
exporting in the first instance well
British manufactured goods which were
mostly textiles which were knockoffs of
things which were being produced in
South Asia anyway it's an important
story a story but in the 1760s and 1770s
there was absolutely an obsession with
with with with South Asia in these in
North America and increasingly of course
the great Bengal famine of 1769 - uh -
well depending on how you dated 1769 to
1784 also led to to a great a great set
of concerns in North America as an
example of a crate great colonial
mistake and I think you know part of
Cervantes work has provided evidence for
empirical evidence for actually what
happened but the big point is that by
the middle of the 18th century for for
those in the Atlantic there was no
strict separation between an Atlantic
and Persian at world there was a kind of
an aspiration to some sort of
globalization in a variety of ways so
why why then did did Styles write this
in in the in the late 18th century well
in in the 16th and 17th century Britons
were obsessed with the Ottoman Empire
and I think it's obviously true that
they were it wasn't a condescending view
they sort of recognized Ottoman power
and they work uniformly anti-islamic in
fact recent work including a work by
Bill Pullman who I gather is speaking at
this moment at UConn talking about a
British admiration for for various forms
of the Ottoman Empire etc so so there
was this you know real obsession concern
with the Ottoman Empire and it was
associated I think increasingly the
trade into the Mediterranean in the
bridge in the Atlantic world was
associated with conservatism
conservatism both a social
socioeconomically that is to say it
tended to be elites who were focused on
the Mediterranean world in terms of
trade it with it was a low risk a
guaranteed reward strategy and this is
you know a point that was made by
Professor Subramanyam colleague Bob
Brenner a generation ago but it was also
conservative in the sense that it was it
was the high churchmen in the most
conservative because clerics in in the
Atlantic who were very who wrote mostly
about the Ottoman world now there was a
very different view of the Persian at
world recent work by Nabil Matar has
shown that they were almost exclusively
in the 17th and 18th century sympathetic
accounts of the Safavid Empire and the
Mughal empires in in the British the
British world now a Matar says this is
probably because they didn't know very
much but I think that's certainly true
but I also think it's in part in part
because because of various accounts that
they had coming back from from merchants
in a variety of ways and there was also
a material appreciation of Mughal and
Safavid production and that seems to be
given a fillip recently by work by
Maxine Berg and her group of work very
little of which has been published so
far I mean that the individual books
have been published but the major
publication of the sort of material
consumption has has not been shown and
and increasingly I think there was this
kind of
dialectical perception in the 18th
century there was a conservative view
which focus very much on the Levant and
on the Mediterranean and there was
increasingly in the in the 18th century
a consumption a desire to look at
ottoman copies or knockoffs of of South
Asian calicos for example that were
flooding into Western European markets
and for for these kind of Atlantic
traders it was the kind of conservative
groups who tended to focus on on on the
Mediterranean on the other hand there
was this kind of Pro Mughal view
especially that that was perpetrated
both by by far more radical merchants in
a variety of ways and in a variety of
texts but also culturally for example
John Dryden Zoran Zev of 1675 was in a
remarkably sympathetic account of the
Mughal Empire and it's interesting that
that text was republished and performed
again both in London and it turns out
recently we know in New York in 1763 as
a critique of the kind of climate view
of what was go of what was going on so I
just wanted yeah I guess yeah I guess
without what I'll do is though it's not
to take up too much time is to sort of
think about how the the ways in which in
British historiography the first and
this division between the first and
second Empire is in fact a conservative
invention associated with the followers
of Lord North's government it is it sort
of understands the key to Empire as
being an extractive model in a variety
of ways as and so there's a movement
from extraction in this story from the
Western Hemisphere to extraction in the
eastern hemisphere whereas the
alternative model which was was one with
sort of focused on Empire as
confederation and forms
exchange in which case in their view in
fact the model which they imagined to
have been perpetrated both in in South
Asia that it's a safe to recall that
their view of what the successor states
were were sort of a form of
Confederation but also an imagination of
a world of of Confederations in a
variety of ways which would seek peace
through various forms of exchange so it
does strike me it does strike me so part
of part of what what I'm trying what I'm
trying to suggest is that there was at
least in the 18th century an emergence
of a kind of global vision which placed
which placed all of these different
cultural zones in dialogue with each
other rather than as sort of self
enclosed possibilities and it strikes me
that it has been very muchly a
particularly kind of conservative
historiography from the 18th century not
not later which has tried to talk about
talk about hermetically hermetically
sealed zone so that doesn't mean that
there isn't any reality to separate
cultural spheres but these cultural
spheres also were interactive and so I
think it's a question of trying to sort
of reimagine how we sort of tell this
story in a variety of ways and I've said
more than enough I should go back to
playing Game of Thrones now thank you so
much I think it's a bad time that we
would ask persisted Romania to try to
tell us some of these reflections words
from what we heard from our panel and
some of these thoughts on gender
diversity her last few days from the
audience and some of the issues that
they raised you know that may be a
chance for you to try to engage us in
this right thank you you have come a lot
from me so I should try to be relatively
um so let me actually try to organize my
talks around about four maybe four and a
half themes so first basic question
which I want to ask is this I mean
beyond the purely academic what is
actually at stake in other terms then we
employ notions such as such as
passionate where does it actually take
us and where does it take us actually in
terms of some other somewhat broader
discussions now I think a useful place
to start is a debate which took place
about a decade ago give or take in the
indian journalistic sphere not
immediately after but sometime after a
series of publications by by service
life poll on the question of Islam and
its impact on on India and in fact Islam
and its impact more largely on the
Indian Ocean world you would recall most
of you I'm sure that Nepal's brought
thesis was that the problem with Islam
was that it was always higher archiving
there was always a pure center and then
increasingly impure peripheries which
felt inadequate because they felt they'd
never quite met up to the standards of
the pure center and thus as one moved
out from let's say the hedges and Yemen
outwards into Iran or India and even
further into Indonesia Muslims felt more
and more inadequate and angry and so on
and so forth and this was essentially a
part of a sort of model of diffusion and
dilution as it went on and of course one
of the examples that he chose to pick up
in his various speeches he made in India
at that time went back to his earlier
writings in which actually he picked up
on the Deccan as a particular example
and he actually had a particular
understanding of the Deccan of the
frontier there right and he recalled
having visited famously
the ruins at hampi where
they had once been a great city of
Vijayanagara and that city had declined
in the aftermath of a war and conquest
in the second half of the sixteenth
century and he actually spoke about how
sort of wandering through the ruins he
felt emotionally desolated cetera et
cetera
and he presented this very much as a
situation where there had been a very
radical frontier there
frontier between one kind of quality and
other kind of quality and that frontier
had been breached and this is the these
are the consequences that had had arisen
now someone wrote a response to him
someone who I cannot say I have
unconditional admiration for which is
vision dalrymple but on this occasion I
have to say I did more or less agree
with most of what he said which is to
say that Dalrymple pointed out that not
all didn't have a very clear
understanding of what polity of
Vijayanagar actually looked like and to
actually see it in some sense as
radically opposed to that of the decade
some tenets that I was talking about
day before yesterday was a mistake let
me just lay out for you what it means by
saying it was a mistake right so we know
and this is something which muzaffer
alum and I wrote about at some length in
a book on in depression travels not in
the 1440 is a traveller from from Erath
and semarang called observes African Lee
was sent by the Tamura drooler is a
shadow to India he was actually sent to
the coast to see whether the coastal
Muslim communities would read the hotbar
in Pharaoh's name he failed in
negotiating that and he actually did not
like the coastal Muslims of India partly
because of a simple reason which is even
in the early 16th century if you are in
an area like Calicut for instance
diplomatic correspondence in Kerala and
early 16th century is carried out in
Arabic now he then made his way into the
interior came to Vijay Nagar and then he
found he was in his comfort zone he
found that this court actually was
didn't use the term but I will use the
term a person ate cook the ruler was a
Hindu but the court's functioning the
court's ceremonial had elements that had
been transmitted from elsewhere I will
say actually that if you if you track
the roots of it of course a lot of the
ceremonial is is a Sicilian derived but
he found himself in the situation that
is quite comfortable he talks about this
at some length of course there were
Persian speakers there as well most
people from Hormuz whom eventually of
the rock fell out with that's a
different matter
but we can actually see a level of
familiarity a level of communication and
a sense of belonging to something which
is if it's not exactly a common cultural
world the cultural world which is at a
high level of continuity with so that I
think is where it becomes useful to
consider the possibility that Persian it
is a useful way of treating something
like vagina which is not clearly a
Muslim Kingdom which is not a kingdom
where you might say Christian culture
dominates there is no substantial
literary production so far as we know in
virginity but nevertheless it is in some
senses you might think of it as the
eighth of Persian eight is actually
about being in some sense the penumbra
of a of a portion of Accession culture
give you a second example about two
hundred forty years later in the late
17th century and here I'll bring myself
closer to Steve Pincus a number of
rather unscrupulous Englishmen found
themselves in an area called 10a serum
which is the Bay of Bengal port of the
Thai Kingdom at that time the Thai
kingdom at the time sixteen fifty sixty
seventy s was ruled over by foreigner I
these Englishmen famously were their two
brothers one of whom the most famous of
them is Samuel white and they were quite
astonished on entering this kingdom the
time
kingdom we are listening 52 1660s the
king is stylee's buddhist but who is
effectively running the show a mantle
akiyama's asana body right who is he
he's obviously a and an Iranian he is
the lira lien who's of the second
generation of Iranians who have
dominated this court there has been a
mantle of the resort Golani before that
they are not the only group of
foreigners present in the court they are
in rivalry with a set of sort of an
earlier generation of descendants of
Japanese ronin who have come out of the
Japanese civil wars of the late
sixteenth early 17th century so that's
them there are Mikasa Reis there are
there's of course this curious figure
called Falcone the Greeks in
Thessalonica but what is really
interesting is this is the fact of this
Iranian presence in Thailand
these Iranians we have told actually
abridged the shahnameh and translated
into the into time we unfortunately does
not survive we also told that they
persuaded night to eat lamb and mutton
which was not in habit of doing
otherwise and so on and so forth that we
started on some occasions adopting
Persian style dress 1 all the wire of
course never converting to Islam never
actually becoming a Muslim and
incidentally what is particularly
interesting for me is that these were
not Iranians from Iran is very Iranian
from the Deccan so these are actually
people who have been settled in the
Deccan and came from volcko an
unhackable
now this was an interesting again
episode where you can actually see
something which you could think of as
part of a penumbra of what are the
dancing of usefully as a person 8
culture not a culture where eventually
person dominates it's one where Persian
is one of the elements in play amongst
others it seeps into other aspects of
the of the of the culture eventually
that is pushed back there are many
fashions which can be asked about
trickle down and
you know whether you're sort of common
or garden type present insensibly
actually cares one way or the other
perhaps he doesn't or she doesn't but is
any data can actually see this kind of
an of an of an effect being being
produced so I think this is a context in
which it is worth thinking about where
we're you know this idea person it takes
us it takes us again in sort of forces
us to rethink the simplistic notions of
frontier and frontier is impermeability
that people like like nightfall still
love to propagate now of course it
doesn't mean that communication was
always in everywhere possible and it
doesn't mean that there were not sort of
a Poirier and there were not moments of
of sort of letters messages and bottles
that never got to anybody and I'll give
you an example of that which can take me
now somewhat to the to the West the
famous example but perhaps wanted to of
you may not know it in the 1630s
shatterhand for some reason decided he
was going to send this present to charge
the first and he sent him a very
lavishly Illustrated copy of the oldest
son of sadi this this manuscript
actually who eventually is learned of
the chester deity libraries in dublin
and you can actually read it sort of
Flyleaf inscription dedicated to this
pattern or Mollica english tongue bye
bye bye she helped with involve muchacha
Hammond but rigazzi so why did he do
this
he did it I mean I'm guessing because of
course the goodest an is a didactic text
it's a text in some sense about about
kingship and so kind of a mirror of
principles of some sort it's also a sort
of a secular text it doesn't have
probably you couldn't think of it really
as a heavily Islamic mix I mean if you
are sending a text to the Ottoman and
Emperor you might send him a very lovely
calligraphed chorale you're not going to
send this to shower first all right
but what happens there is the problem
which is well in 1630 and nobody
affected me in charge the first circles
knows how to be impression there are
some people who read Arabic at this
point in England there's an hourly chair
which is just about to be created by
Archbishop laud and so on but what
happens to it they just sort of throw it
into the low Royal Library and forget
about it for 170 years and then the
early 19th century the the Hanoverians
are thinking of sending in an embassy to
the cut-offs and so they're looking for
a present and they dig into the library
pulls all it's not out and send it to
the cutouts so it goes off there and
then of course it eventually disappears
and comes up onto the oxygen market in
the early 20th century right but here's
an example of where persian culture
actually doesn't help you to communicate
it they try to communicate the question
it doesn't really get it doesn't really
really get anywhere and it sort of
optimism of shah jahan who actually
believes that you know everyone's who
civilized anywhere in the world must
know must know that level of passion
anyway you use the girls time to learn
persian so they should have at least
bothered to do that so there is this
question then that that there are these
limits and and these limits are real
limits but um I don't think this loads
are always the most obvious ones and let
me make then my fourth point as it
happened the first thing I did on coming
to New Haven before I even gave my
lectures was of course I went to the
violently to work on the shaft line
collection all right now let me remind
you what the sharp line collection is
over here right so it is the collection
of the two brothers they shout shout
down and then yell shot down Josh Bazar
who let me remind you very famously not
really went to Iran and brought back an
enormous amount of knowledge about Iran
and presented an extremely positive
image of Iranian mysticism to some
extent of shiism and so on in the
Western in the Western world who was in
some senses as his biography by death
from the crisis caused and shoved on
latesh song was how he was called right
but
there was also someone who actually
accompanied William the third on his
disembarkation in England on his fleet
he actually went with him because he was
so angry with the French and with the
Catholics that he had changed his name
he was now called Sir John schaffner no
longer john shafte
and he had become effectively become a
naturalized Englishman by the end of his
life if you actually look at Sharon's
letters they were so dense boring
letters the ones you have over here they
especially commercial letters but you
actually trace out the network of these
letters and it is exactly the kind of
network that you're talking about right
it's a network which it's the letters
are roughly in five languages there are
no Persian letters there but there are
letters in English in French in Spanish
and Portuguese and a few in rather
strange Venetian dialect so if you
actually look at all those letters you
can see these intersecting networks
which take you from Madras to the
Persian Gulf which takes you to the
Levant which take you into France and of
course there are the few letters which
link him up this le hui' Yale which is
the reason why I presume they bought the
letters and put them into the binding in
the first place right so you can
actually see these overlapping effects
these overlapping networks which take us
from this portion world into other
worlds without necessarily Persian being
the language here which is always the
lingua franca so well I mean of what I
would say to you is is this that the
Persian it for me is something which I
think helps us because it pushes back
against the most simplistic notions of
frontier which for us often in in in
India and so on unfortunately neither
come from you know the American frontier
nor from let's say the Eurasian history
but come from really those extremely
sort of civilizational notions of walls
that's how we often conceptualize
frontiers whereas I think pushing it
allows us to think in terms of much more
sort of porous zone so let me give you
the last
last point which is my little anecdote
with which I often amuse my students
which is something that you might not
which is most concerning a funny
character called Captain John slick
right of course his household name in in
in these parts of the world now I don't
know how many of you know the prehistory
of Captain John Smith which is of course
that Captain John Smith the story that
he account so that before he ever talked
about coming to America went off to
fight the Ottomans and he was actually
engaged in the frontier Wars in Hungary
and Malaysia and so on and so forth and
the first part of his life and he tells
him throughout the extraordinary story
in an autobiographical account of how he
was eventually captured by a Turkish
Pasha and he's and taken to his house in
this near the sea of azov and of course
this was very curious because what
happens there is that eventually he gets
into trouble and he's about to be killed
then something strange happens which is
the wife of the Turkish Pasha falls in
love with him and pleads with the pasha
for his life and he spared so captain
John Smith's life seems to spin another
repetative pattern let me say so either
this was a Turkish but we kept using
again and again or his life actually was
like that but at any rate this is the
reason why Captain John Smith's own own
symbol is three touched heads and this
is the reason why if you go up to two to
the area of Boston there are these
islands which are called Turks heads and
which were actually named for that by
Captain John Smith's encounter and not
with the person it was but at least to
the optimum alright thank you so much
for this Ray engaging conversation here
I think it's just about time that you
would open up
to the floor and see whether there are
some questions or comments from our
audience
sure please can you hold on for one
second past we can give you the
microphone so you can be heard in our
recording all these recordings by the
way is going to be on the Yale lab of
audio videos available online and also
on the sides of C Daniels PA program
analysis and for like beyond talkin hey
so what exactly what I think is the
difference between the cattle with the
passionate spear are the trying to get
some kind of difference between how the
sources talk about you know the the tech
and how they are thinking about at the
present that might be the possible
possible sort of tensions between these
two turned Indian miraculous especially
in any instance with as well Turk is
often simply interchangeable with Muslim
right
kirochka is interchangeable with Muslim
I mean look at the range of words which
are used for Muslim in Sanskrit are
tanishka then Hoonah right so Hanna
sometimes the late chat but that's much
more generally for all kinds of
foreigners right and then
rarely the term parsec appears but in
standard usages for instance in plumber
and family the standard word for Muslim
is to occur which is which is that so
this is them religiously marked and I
think that the point to be made is that
there's a distinction between a term
which is so very heavily religiously
marks
however ethnically do not how much of an
ethnic denomination it's meant to be at
the start and person which is not at all
religiously marked right so I think
that's the the basic the basic
distinction and you know that book from
a volume in which conference in which I
did participate beyond Turkey and Hindu
I mean you know where it comes from it
actually comes from a Marathi text right
which is the Sun God by a cloud right so
there again it is the thing is it would
never have been the Parsee into some
bath right the the equivalence is being
made between Turkey and Hindu here is
anyone else would like to respond to
that anyone else before we move on I
actually have a comment immensely we see
up we had a of course hear about the
problematizing the notion of the acumen
that Alan is a very deliciousness of
what we just we heard from Sanjay the
points that indeed this kind of an idea
of passionate did not carry any
particular religious weight with it it
was more of a neutral world in a sense
that the language was not as Richard
Eaton pointed out a sacred language like
attributes for instance or Sanskrit for
that not
so the language in which text could be
easily transmitted from all the ideas
could be transmitted from one culture to
another and fast that was part of the
reason why there was a greater reception
this activity for for passion as a
language because it could China as we
saw yesterday the DOS animosity
inversion easily across or in the
Ottoman context as well we would see
that much of the early literature a
person is preferred because it's a
language in which the Islamic context is
not so heavily emphasized and I would
like to say that in that context
probably the idea of the person is
remain something neutral when when you
see it in Central Asia or when you see
in South Asia it's not a curiously
enough it even after 16th century it was
not associated with cheeser
of the doorknob it was very curious so
you would not consider Persian as being
the language of the Persian language of
the Iranian or the Shiites heretics over
the way they would have been and I mean
yes once again I mean of course that is
exactly the point right there which is
the ongoing for which we discussed the
other day informally which is that that
that you know the Indians by the 17th or
the 18th century had had absolutely no
patience with the idea that a person
belonged to the Iranians yes and they
actually started belonged as much to
them as it belongs to the and this is of
course you know the factor the basis of
course was the famous fight between pain
and
and ours and so on and so forth and
eighteenth-century but it's an ongoing
fight which exists from the time of a
brief as a long word yes actually even
family say I'm sorry but actually it's
quite interesting your colleague and
collaborator with our alum recently
wrote an article in which he very
clearly shows that a classification of
Persian poetry the emergence of the
earliest by God very early such Chara's
that appears in subcontinent are all
part of this kind of understanding of
persian as it as a cultural language
once you are outside the supposedly the
mainland and you consider it much more
as your own rather than the rather than
the Iranian Black Sea
I just need to add that I think one of
the things one has to be a little
careful with though I think in over
emphasizing the neutrality of it because
I don't think it's neutral right I mean
I think well because I think Persian at
least certainly in the case of India is
an aspirational language so that it's
not socially neutral at all right it's
all about moving up move finding
difference and finally creating
difference and creating those borders I
don't like to think a little bit about
how much of it is also racially marked
it starts to become part of this kind of
crossing over into different territories
cross-dressing linguistically if you
will right who's pretending to be
something and this is the same thing in
Iran - right I mean will they stop
speaking Turkish on the western frontier
and start speaking Iranian there is
something going on in that kind of
changing one's ethnicity or mark those
markers start to change and so I think
there's something about this kind of yes
status on the one hand but also a
different kind of a deeper identity that
language bestows on you so I think maybe
it's not the Turk and the Hindu but
there's something else going on right
then we have to restore Assizes I think
that's the important thing
the subject of Duncan and is it possible
that the parties who went from at the
advent of Islam went from Iran to India
they had something to do to contribute
to the loose Kingdom and their influence
had some effect on the personal world
that you are describing the passes of
course as you as you probably know are
mostly concentrated in the area of
Gujarat heading south eventually into
but this is only in the in the 17th and
18th century that they move down into
the conquer in Gujarat so far as we know
in the sort of what you could broadly
think of as a medieval period they don't
seem to have a very prominent political
role but when you get to the Mughal
period they do have a very interesting
role so for example in the 17th century
the early 18th century there are some
quite prominent
Zoroaster party entrepreneurs and and
actors on in the mughal Suba of gujarat
who are projecting themselves actually
in some very substantial ways there is a
very famous figure for instance called
called rostam de Medici who there's a
whole area of Surat which is named for
him and he actually was he has left all
these public works which actually
carried is very interesting bilingual
inscriptions in gujarati and persian and
then of course the most interesting
thing about him is that he gets a
biographical poem written about himself
which is called kiss I said some monarch
where he is described as the great guy
in fact the greatest thing which is
supposed to have done
is he supposed to have actually
protected suitors from Shivaji that when
Shivaji attacked Surat he supposed to
have got together ransom and paid him
off so that so that the city was
protected so at that point they emerged
into prominence and then of course very
much with the British then into the 18th
century they become very prominent
actors with the with the prediction of
course I will never look back but in the
medieval period it's very difficult to
find them playing a prominent political
role so far as I know so I wanted to go
back to the issue of version and version
8 being neutral and of course has a
really point that socially it is not
neutral but it's also the language of a
big Imperial state such as the Mughal
state and southern reign how does that
shape the ways in which it is not a
neutral language and the reasons why
various groups would want to gain
erudition and the sophisticated level of
you know an ability to deploy its
language but also what is the
relationship of the Persian it and the
Islamic eight because any let's say we
talk about Persian texts it's not that
they're not embedded with quotations
guarana quotations or references to the
religious or metaphors that can be
perceived off as being religious so yeah
when we get back to that idea of the
neutrality of the Persian eight and its
relationship to the Islamic eight I'm
happy to have a go but maybe somebody
else should have a go first when it in
terms of Persians have not sort of the
idea of quote the Persian is in the
Islamic is you know I think that's it's
absolutely right when you look at the
translation of index into Persian you
know which are often domesticated in a
certain way you know sometimes the Indyk
terms remain
there are often in the vernacular forms
of not necessarily from the Sanskrit and
then there are various equivalents that
are given that of course given certain
new valence to the text and then these
text in turn come to be often read by by
Hindus for their own sacred purposes you
know often Hindus are working in
multilingual environments but who might
come to read persian and there are
certain communities who of course more
widely represented in these certain
kinds of brahmins you know pious
countries and others so it often becomes
a sort of hereditary thing I can decide
also I think institutions change this is
so interesting because for example what
I do fieldwork in sins right so you
might have a Sufi shrine and right next
to that you would have actually a Hindu
temple but what they've taken is
interesting you know and this goes to
the idea of language because I think
language at different types of registers
where they would have had meditation
spaces that you know we might associate
so much with a particular kind of
Islamic practice such as chilla
right so to go in and to have this deep
meditation and seconds it's a removal of
yourself that's exactly the same term
that they will use in a Hindu temple now
what happens there right so they're
using a term that we might associate
with a particular religious practice but
they do something with it right and they
appropriated or domesticated I think
that I think is really fascinating kinds
of allusions in poetry that we might if
we think in classical it might have some
kind of mystical it's not like
connection but I think it's being
reappropriation and read in a different
manner altogether you know I think the
if you go back to to the FIR alumns that
the article which is a very important
article called the pursuit of Persian he
has a couple of very interesting points
which he makes at one point which he
makes his district so in that interim
and Humayun is chased out of India and
the source takeover right so the the
it's clear that the shoes are very
tempted by actually adopting Hindi
you can see various signs of it I mean
it's not a coincidence that it's the
soos who invent this coin called the
rupiah which is any word they don't call
it seeker they don't call it by any
person term they don't call it tanker
they call it rupiah and and it remains
with us forever ever since and in fact
you have the few documents that you have
in the period and so on and so forth
it's very clear that the the
administration was being conducted at
least partly in Hindi at that point of
time and then advert comes back and a
bird basically makes clearly makes a
decision to to reimpose or impose much
more clearly Persian which is an
interesting decision because in a way a
Persian you could say it's not really
his language either right so I mean
people I remember once one of my
Southeast Asian colleagues made the
comparison a little anachronistic but
still worth thinking about for instance
of the Indonesians who adopt who adopt a
basa that is to say Malay as a language
which is partly because Malay is
nobody's language really in Indonesia
the the Javanese are obliged them to
learn Malay as a foreign language and it
becomes it creates a very strange effect
and portioned in that sense is has that
strange effect to at the moment that
that it's adopted so in a way it's
aspirational but it's curious it's
aspirational then for everybody and and
in some sense then what it becomes is
and you know the strange figure like
Abul Fazal can only be explained by that
I mean here is a man who who has this
obsession with language who has an
obsession with purifying persian of
trying to extract arabic to the extent
that he can from persian to restore it
to some christine form or something of
this kind and you you know you get you
get all of that but at the same time
often trying to minimize the religious
references than the religious contention
and so on so you see this is fuzzy as
well you know that you actually we know
when when Frazee translates in all the
one for instance you know he's
constantly playing all these tricks but
keeping the the in a way the Islamic
references are to as low a level as he
as he possibly can right so it to my
mind yes I mean the point which Kishore
makes is a very very important point
that it is an aspirational language it's
a language of social distinction and
it's a language which eventually creates
the class distinctions in in in Mughal
India I mean you know the famous I think
in was Affairs article there is a famous
story about you know one of the Nizam
Aziz who at one point heard someone in
the Nizam's Court in the late 18th
century speaking although and he said
you know you northerners using the
Spanish first you kill Persian in North
India now you've come here to kill
Persian as well because you know this
was this is after all what we have left
of our culture and you're trying to kill
it by vernacular rising it right so you
can see that this is what he thought he
had you know left question so one of the
things that was striking is that a
discussion about whether Persian it was
neutral became about whether Persian is
neutral and so the use of Persian is one
decision but you're the panels used
desire to use the term Persian it is a
different phenomenon and that is in fact
I think from what I can hear the the
desire to find a term that is not
necessarily going to bring Islam along
with it so I think that I mean there is
that distinction as well right I mean
clearly there are individuals or there
are moments in time when the choice to
write in Persian or to write in Arabic
in India or elsewhere I can have certain
effects as some of you know I'm
interested in a figure who wrote in both
a bill gourami
and you know even his translations are
interesting because he'll try and he
translates tropes into the other
language as well not just sort of
straightforward translation or whatever
that was one thing
and you mentioned professor broman you
mentioned a Phase II não faz also wrote
an under additional undoubted commentary
on the Koran and so there's still an
they still a fascination it seems with
some aspects of what we would call them
looking at well eg as an Islamic ache as
opposed to the two
what we might call it I mean there would
not be a way of describing that as a
Persian eight phenomenon right and so I
mean I'm not convinced that the
distinction is simple and I think to say
that it's neutral or not neutral is I
don't think terribly productive I mean
it's something else
everything neutrality is a productive
way of thinking about scholarly use of a
term that's seeking a way to be neutral
I think that that's tricky at least it
is for me because I was in a similar
question I just wonder I the panel was
framed as a comparison between a Persian
it ecumene and the Mediterranean
Atlantic Indian Ocean world and I wonder
if the more appropriate comparison here
is the idea of a lab net world which for
a very long time characterized thinking
about Europe again in terms of language
again sort of stuff used by this
question about how do you separate out a
kind of linguistic cultural sphere with
clearly important kind of economic and
other Imperial resonances and to connect
that to the question of Latin
Christendom and the ways in which those
things are also both being separated out
in the same period we're clearly to
write in Latin is in some ways to write
in terms of Latin Christendom it also
means to write in the language that's
spoken widely across a very large area
that is not always already implicated in
questions about Christianity and
increasingly less so as we go on so I
wonder kind of whether that's the useful
comparison point for thinking about the
idea of Persian and Persian it and I
sort of related question is also a
geography which is instructed the
comparison here to the Mediterranean
world it want to call that the Indian
Ocean world I mean all of these are
circulatory regimes driven by oceans and
water and we speak about the lab net and
the Persia net were distinctly not
talking about the same kind of geography
and I wanted to what extent that matters
and my final point about this is the
idea the acumen itself is a Greek idea
and it's a Greek idea derived from a
very particular kind of political
cultural formation that was never
understood to be Greek at the time in
the ancient world but was in some ways
retrospectively characterized as such
and you know this goes back to Steve's
point you're about Empire as considered
raishin which is already a very old idea
going back to the ancient world and I
wanted to what extent what's at stake in
bringing that idea back to talk about
the Persian it was I was really struck
by the use of that term which in some
ways has fallen out of a lot of thinking
of how these formations are
characterized in the ancient war in the
ancient classical world and then
reprised different iterations for the
ronso point I don't know whether I Alan
and Steve would like to listen to this
no can I just say I mean there's a
couple I mean I I was struck and I was a
little Sunday with saying I was tricked
you know there was a debate in the 18th
century at the institution one of the
institutions which Sunday used to teach
that is a Oxford about whether to
actually create a chair of Persian and
Robert or the was prepared to fund such
a chair and it was rejected both by by
the the vice-chancellor and by the crown
meaning the ministry on on the grounds
that on the grounds precisely that we
only teach holy languages and so there
was at least on the perception of the in
the British so you know and obviously
not inside this world but there I mean
this would tend to sort of support your
view that from their perspective I mean
that that this was that the purpose for
learning Persian was cultural rather
than religious whereas of course Arabic
Hebrew was not created as a chair at
Oxford at a time did become a chair of
the chair here actually in the 1760s
were as well yes but no I'm still
looking
that's right yeah but he prefers but yes
then Arabic so there there is something
about that what you raised about Latin
is really quite interesting because I
think in northern Europe there was a
real move away for
I mean there was a real move among the
merchant classes away from wanting Latin
to be the language of instruction in the
Universities precisely because this had
various religious meetings which were
inappropriate for the modern world and
so there's this nice piece that then
riches read along you know a while ago
actually showing that there was this
kind of argument in Leiden about whether
they should just you know teach in Dutch
and the argument turned precisely
precisely about that the question I mean
what you raise about I'm the sort of
question about about the sea versus
versus land is is an interesting
question because I mean my view and this
has sort of been my concern about you
know thinking about the Atlantic and
again I mean you know I've obviously
somewhat critical of rodell's vision for
for similar reasons is that is that I'm
the precise point about this I mean
about the sea about these people whose
race is precisely its open-endedness and
I so I mean I think that is sort of an
geographically opener geographically
open-ended this of course I mean the
Atlantic was never associated with the
language in any sort of way and you know
I mean there was obviously a period in
which the Mediterranean was but but I
you know I'm and it's an interesting and
interesting set of questions but I you
know I mean what you say about I mean
absolutely the the Confederation 'lest
notion which was you know as you say I
mean completely tied to to an ancient
world to a Greek world and was very
closely tied up in the amphictyonic
league is something that sort of comes
up over and over again as a way of sort
of reimagining I mean so a lot of the
discourse the 17th and 18th century
discourse about perpetual peace turns on
Confederations and is precisely trying
to transcend both you know political and
economic conflict but also religious
conflict and that Confederations
Confederations need not be and of course
I mean this was this was a discussion
both with respect to the ancient world
as having the whole point of discussing
the
Swiss Confederation is precisely that
it's multi-confessional and so
Confederation is a way of perpetuating
peace and getting religion you know and
not out of the story but it's not a
central element of the story in fact I
think I mean I'm very really sympathetic
to the question of thinking through
oceans right and I'm thinking especially
about the Indian Ocean I think is really
important
precisely for our work because it brings
in the wet east coast of africa which i
think is so important for thinking about
dispersion eight world and I think
that's something we really do need to
interrogate a little bit more because if
we go along the language of Swahili but
also the mode again of kingship and
authority as of really basing themselves
on this weird sort of overlapping of an
imperial version eight Islamic eight I
don't know how you want to get meat to
be chased out identity so Indian Ocean
is useful for broadening the scope I
think actually of the same thing but
look at where the cities are the big
cities that we're talking about least in
the early modern region are all
landlocked they are not and so when we
start putting emphasis on the Indian
Ocean we really are looking at it again
from a very European perspective of
trade networks and I think we want to be
careful about not over emphasizing the
importance of these Mediterranean world
is one thing but it's really not the
same thing in the Indian Ocean and so
you want to be careful not to think of
those as equivalences ya know look I
think that we have to be careful because
the the say these large spatial
categories which are designed
essentially to encompass different
political formations and therefore to
sort of break away from typical
historiography which tends to focus on
the biographies of political formations
are not obviously all the same and to my
mind if I were to actually think about
where everyone could go usefully with
something like the Persian it
for instance one direction in which I
would go is in the direction of going
back to and interrogating and thinking
about Sheldon Pollux
sort of Sanskrit Cosmopolis now that's
an interesting idea it's also
interesting because again Sanskrit is a
language which has which has these sort
of aspirational features to it but then
a person obviously the parallelisms
break down very quickly because Sanskrit
is a very exclusivist language the whole
social groups who cannot and are not
meant to learn it which is never the
case with Persian there is the sort of
the sacral side to it which is and so on
and so forth I mean it's interesting in
the middle between these two there's for
instance a quite interesting work of
Rani 3qi who's tried to make the
argument of taking this into the
question of Arabic in the Indian Ocean
not Arabic in its Western in its Western
incarnation which is another story so I
think that those are those are one set
of logics where one is essentially sort
of working through a language culture
complex and then there's another logic
which i think is so in for instance if
one were to do that more in the
direction of the Atlantic I would be so
then thinking of let's say an Iberian
because I mean after all Spanish and
Portuguese are so mutually intelligible
that you would then actually have so it
would not be the Atlantic quad planting
it would actually be the Atlantic of the
Iberian swith perhaps the Philippines
thrown into the mix and bits of North
Africa that would be the didi the
appropriate the appropriate closer
closer comparison so yes sometimes you
know when one is sort of taking a very
spatial construct whether it's based on
ocean whether it's based on some other
kind of frontier and then one is doing
something else which is actually very
flexible based really on on a sort of a
language culture thing there are the
apples and oranges it's absolutely it's
absolutely the case but sometimes of
course it's so true that you know the
botanists may be horrified by the idea
that you can produce hybrids between
apples and oranges in there but before
then teacher carries this question I
think he's about to leave I have to yeah
I was wondering whether I can you know
make some suggestions as to yes whether
we have to we have to be very careful
about not making this dichotomy of
Persian versus Arabic and there is much
area that between the two languages or
the two - geographical regions there is
a great degree of conversation and give
and take notice but I actually perhaps
one important suggestion is that this
division of labor early in the Islamic
world between what Arabic is to our
deliverer in terms of religious sciences
in terms of exact sciences versus
Persian who progressively became a
language of literature in the Eastern
Islamic world became a language of his
geography and largely contributed to
Sufism so in a sense sacredness in
person is a person Texas quite often as
associated with two feet X which was
much easier to to transmit either Sufi
ideology / Sufi ideas or a Sufi poetry a
final time of Hajj video on words we
would see all of this Persian texts in
Sufism grows where as you would see far
less text in law issues of Sharia very
few translations you would see of Sahar
on the Untersee issue on hadith emerging
in Persian the same level that you would
see this other areas of science or
knowledge has has explored in Persia so
it seems to me there was some kind of
division of labor
we are almost informally observed
throughout including the subcontinent
was quite a number as you know better
than I do quite a number of a space of
of scholars in the field writing both
languages wrote in both languages and
producing different fields okay so um
I'm interested in this question of what
are the boundaries of the Persian it has
an acumen which Alan first brought up
and we're talking a lot about this in
terms of the Indian Ocean and South Asia
but I'm thinking from my own work
looking at the northern end of this
Persian at ecumene and I think from the
Russian perspective on this when the
Russians sort of come into contact with
Iran across the Caspian Sea there is a
sense that this is a a meaningful
cultural frontier but the Russians are
often conceptual I think that's not as
the frontier with the Persian world but
between the Slavic and the Turkic this
is part of the sort of Russian
conception of the why of field of the
southern step which would stretch all
the way from the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth to Central Asia and when
they approach Iran oftentimes it's being
done not in Persian as the language of
diplomacy but in fact in Turkic
languages so that you know when the
Russian Consul Boogaloo buff comes to
Keylong in 1768 his interpreters and no
guy Prince because he can speak a Turkic
language which would be known in Iran
and so I'm wondering first of all
whether or not it occurs to me that the
perception of what this is a frontier of
or a boundary of depends on a certain
Center and perspective here right so it
may appear as a frontier of the Persian
it from within a environment which
Persian court culture and Persian
language are dominant but from the
Russian from if we take saint-petersburg
as a center it's a very different kind
of cultural frontier and so I'm
wondering maybe if just to kind of pick
up on what Professor subramanyam said
with the example from the Thai kingdom
with where you have this Persian this
Persian at Persian language presence
alongside people from Japan people from
other parts of Southeast Asia from the
Deccan whether or not we should think of
their the Persian at being anywhere
where Persian is why
of several competing cultural and
linguistic influences or whether or not
there are boundaries of that we can
clearly define it all sure um let's see
yeah I mean I think the question that
Kevin is raising is a very good question
I mean I think points to some of the
problems with the term or the concept I
mean one can sort of always find counter
examples to something clearly I don't
know how many how many at what point do
the counter examples of you know make an
alternative case I'm not sure I think if
the concept is wherever Persian is
spoken amongst one of a number of
languages being part of the Persian
eight world and that's not very useful
as a concept that I mean frankly I mean
I sort of agree with with I think some
of the the points that both shellcodes
and I show were raising of trying to
poke a little at the concept it's not
clear to me it's not clear to me the the
utility of it and I think you know
you're pointing to another counter
example of that I mean I think it's
telling do we have do we have similar
sorts of concepts coming out of
different cultural fields I mean we
could talk about this I mean you know
the Turkish nationalists a certain brand
of Turkish nationals I could speak about
a Turkic world that's a you know that's
stretched to the Central Asian Republics
okay there's a connection sure but up
you know beyond that it's not it's not
clear to me what we would we get from
from pointing that out which is not a
sort of answer to your question but um
but I think you're pointing to some of
the of the of the problems
I mean from home and it's pretty much an
outsider here it strikes me that the
value of any of these kind of cultural
concepts is always relational and it's
conceived of in terms of the binary so I
mean I in terms of Isis conception of
Latin Christendom it's the question is
in comparison to what and and so it
strikes me that this this I mean this is
kind of a soft defensive position that
that it strikes me that that just poking
that there are exceptions and we can set
configurations all that means is that
there are different relations that one
could imagine so in other words I mean
in sort of mathematical terms it strikes
me that one wants to think about sets in
relationship to other sets in terms of
cultures which means that they're going
to look differently from different
relational point of view points of view
that doesn't mean that there isn't some
value in the concept and so I think I
mean I think from from that point of
view I mean I guess I don't see this in
said criticism I see this as merely an
observation of a mathematical truth so I
mean I mean maybe that's I mean again
this is this is the problem of having
been a math major as an undergraduate I
still see things in these purely
mathematical terms but it does strike me
that that I mean it does strike me that
that various concepts are always ended
up themselves relational and therefore
the question that you want to ask is in
relationship to at what and if it is so
it doesn't necessarily make it less
valuable to say that and that something
that you're thinking of with relation to
it 2x doesn't have any value with
reduction to Zed doesn't affect me as a
criticism I mean if we if we want to
give you know Hudson to some some credit
so let's actually try to go back to see
what is he trying to do by introducing
these two concepts which are clearly in
his own mind related concepts of Islamic
it and Persian it so let's at least you
know give him
the full possible full possible should
we say you know space to to to to to
defend himself in his absence so to
speak so to my mind and and since I was
an econ major not a math one I mean it
in fact the concept does exist it's what
is known as a fuzzy set alright so and
this this and this notion of a fuzzy set
is exactly what it seems to me Hodgson
hasn't as in mind that doesn't say it's
something where basically the a very
sharp frontier which defines what is
inside and what is outside is is not
valid and now he's trying to apply that
at two levels so for example at the
level of religion so Islamic it implies
there may be people who are not exactly
Muslims but who are not exactly not
Muslims right I mean which as we know is
there is I mean as anyone who's worked
for instance on religious history in
India knows that I mean there's a huge
number of people who when the first
censuses were made in India when they
were asked if they were Muslim said yes
and if they ask the Hindus they also
said yes right and then progressively
the census forced them to say no you
know whatever this famous in which reign
Besson Ian speak or die is what they
said to them right they said you have to
make up your mind you can't be both
right and and in a certain sense so
there's an analogous thing with a
different category so you no longer
using language are you no longer using
religion but language and culture in
your making that argument that there is
that sort of penumbral penumbral zone
around that's what he was he was I guess
trying to trying to do now I mean in
some sense it seems to me that if we
believe that by introducing this he's
only muddied the waters then we have two
options we can either go back to the non
fuzzy said the extremely sharp
definition which it seems to me is in a
very bad idea or then we have to take a
third position which is to say we
neither accept the
sharp definition nor the fuzzy set
definition then let's come up with a
third thing which is neither of these
two and that I think would be you know
taking on Watson properly on his own
terms
they also indicate what you would like
to know I just wanna I just wanted to
say I think I think it's the the work of
pointing out the fact that a concept
like the Islamic world or the Ottoman
Empire it's already is already a fuzzy
set I take that to be the fuzzy set I
mean we all know that it within the
Islamic world there are plenty of
non-muslims there are plenty of people
who have you know various kinds of
identities that overlapped within the
Ottoman Empire again the majority of the
people for the first 150 years were
Christians all of that is embedded
already in the concept so it's the
purchase of those terms it's not clear
to me exactly what we get from that I
mean of course I see it and I'm trying
to sort of to be devil's advocate but
with this but it it strikes me that it's
it's at some points fuzzy to the point
of non-utility and then what and then
then what purchase do we have from the
from those from those terms and person
it is very useful in an early modern
context I think especially we haven't
talked a lot about politics I mean Steve
try to insert politics a little bit did
I mean the fact of a fairly big set of
empires in the Muslim world makes these
kinds of I'm still wedded to the idea
that it is a cultural phenomenon that
we're talking about here makes that more
attractive at some level and gets us
outside of thinking about just the
Imperial state maybe within the Ottoman
Empire and an ottoman is are often are
often accused of this what being Ottoman
means having a relationship to the state
and Persian it in breaking out of that
kind of mold of thinking about early
modernity I think is quite it is quite
useful but you know I could talk about
you know Ottoman merchants and others
speaking Turkish in various parts of the
world the same with Arabic
I mean not other cultural cultural modes
of being and would we describe that as
as a kind of you know Turk eight world
it's not clear to me if I may actually
in defensive arts and also point out
that he wrote in the 60s against the
history of goofy which profoundly
basically ignored that layer of cultural
exchange in the particularly Cenozoic
world and draw the attention to the
importance of that world I mean he was
writing yes this scholarship of people
like Gib like Brooklyn man like all
these great scholars of the of the
Islamic civilizations or Islam as a
whole that put the whole of the emphasis
into this kind of a canonical Arabic
literature as a foundation of Islamic
Islamic world and he tried to think much
more try to in a sense problematized the
notion by bringing that look much had
happened in this is an Islamic world
that was very different in terms of its
focus in terms of its contribution to
what he called Islamic eight and not
Islam per se and then it says broke away
if we like from the he may have
introduced a new oriental eyes nation
notion but at the same time he it seems
to me that he tried to break away from
the old notions of Islamist being Arabic
and Iran and nothing else you see and
the Islamic Sciences so in that regard I
think he's for his time this was a very
important contribution no I mean I don't
mean to at all take anything away from
Hudson's contribution I mean he's one of
the first people right to do
Islamic history is global history right
I mean that's a very important it's a
very important moment and he's writing
as I understand at the same moment that
William McNeil was writing his rise at
the West at Chicago so the end of our
time and you have your game of this
about yesterday didn't ask you now you
mentioned in her name I have here having
this sort of Machiavellian account of
the Taking of Toledo but thinking of in
this tariff in the ass of the the
Ottoman conquest of Cairo where he
mentions very sort of unflattering
aspects of Salim's
you know campaign in the east but how
was this sort of the result at at and
the kind of immoral behavior in conquest
and etc handled the reconciled in in
maybe bridge net history or I mean in
general this is kind of a very general
question I'm not a specialist in this
field but how is this sort of you know
James behaving bad we're doing bad
things in battle etc justified etcetera
you know and looking at even yes and the
conquest of men look
Egypt specifically because it was the
case thank you thank you so I find that
a lot of the conversations center around
this idea of grasping what is the the
Persian it domain and I'm actually
interested in sort of when does the
Persian at end and this again is sort of
drawing off of Kevin what you were
sharing about your personal answers in
the northern frontier I'm sort of
studying sort of different empires in
this idea of frontiers in Rover one and
I'm like how much of that is Persian it
to what extent we can describe that as
Persian that when most of the actors
involved in this encounter
don't speak the language don't share a
culture can we identify this as a person
at story when when does the person at
end essentially or are we still living
in a pertinent world or person at worlds
thank you and I presume by end you mean
my terms of chronology
precisely like in terms of yeah space of
time very quickly to answer the first
question I mean the interesting point is
this that if you read Chronicles and so
on where you get these these particular
aspects of something which happens which
is some non-standard form of behavior or
non-approved form of behavior you can
get a specific explanation which pops up
which often has to do with the character
of the person involved and things of
this kind somebody asked me a question
yesterday which i think is the put its
finger on the essential thing which is
how curious it is that the mirror for
princess genre very often in the Persian
world refuses to engage precisely with
these kinds of concrete examples which
are out there in the Chronicles so
there's a kind of a very often a
separation and what Maivia does very
oddly is by using this example he
actually infiltrates the historical
record much more into the mirror of
princes genre and then he therefore in a
way he twists the genre in a in a
particular in a particular direction so
it's not something which in general you
would find that everything in a which
happens historically and which is
recorded in a chronicle has to have a
theoretical explanation for it
see so that's the interesting
interesting point which is not your
question I mean it's you know in the
last year my colleague Niall green
organized three conferences on different
aspects of the Persian eight world
right on the on the the geographical
limits on the epistemological limits and
so on and so forth and at the end of
those three conferences I have to say
that we were not a lot more advanced
than we were to be are today and and
certainly I think that the the question
which you which you would you raise
I mean does remain open because I think
a lot of people would argue that the
personate world certainly as it exists
today has very different geographical
contours than what it might have had in
the 18th century but that he does not
come to an end it just is a very
different looking world than than than
that world and and in that sense I mean
of course if you cease to use the term
person it the question is moot but on
the other hand if you continue to want
to use it I think that you could you
would want to use it in the present
tense perhaps on that point we had to
bring our I think fascinating discussion
in the panel and they would like to
thank all of my colleagues here and the
guest speaker for this I think important
occasion I like the idea of what you
said and I think that would be a very
good definition of what especially it
could be and I think it goes well with
the new trends of history ography is and
don't look for something very fixed and
the person is the fuzzy set makes make
sense
but of course I grad student student
here that part like saying all of that
thank you very much for bearing for us
with two eyes for this discussion
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you